Rivers bring
water the element essential to all life
on
Earth but wherever rivers flow they also
bring
death surprise
attacks Savage
kills and brutal fights
every day is a battle for survival on
these rivers of
[Applause]
death I'm under the African Sun Staying
Alive is hot thirsty
work and among the ranks of animals
jostling to get a
drink lurk Killers waiting to
strike
[Music]
but while Lions may be
fearsome and the huge Nile crocodiles
ruthless
Predators one of the continent's
deadliest River Killers is mostly
[Music]
vegetarian renowned wallowers spending
up to 16 hours a day lounging in the
water
hippos could be mistaken for relaxed
[Applause]
creatures and yet the river horse as
their name translates from ancient Greek
can be a very angry pony
indeed with tusks up to a foot and a
half long hippos are literally armed to
the
teeth and a charging bull Hipp can
impact with the weight force of a pickup
truck what's more hippos May brutally
defend their
territory an Impala has been chased into
a muddy Watering Hole by a
lion it's
stuck but for fortunately for the
stricken analou the lion is reluctant to
follow it into the
Meer unfortunately it finds itself in
the domain of a hippo ill disposed to
uninvited
guests the hippo's not stealing the
watching Lion's
meal she's most likely just aggressively
defending her
calf and the Impala pays the ultimate
price for crossing a doting
mother
hippos are thought to kill more people
each year than the rest of Africa's most
dangerous animals
combined and during mating season their
ruthless aggression is directed at other
hippos two bulls square up the pod's
dominant male and a
Challenger
at stake the Riverbanks Prime mating
territory and a Herm of
females the dominant male puts on an
aggressive
display posturing to show he will not
yield but the interloper Demands a
fight
finally the dominant male is
Victorious the Conqueror celebrates with
a dung shower marking the border of the
territory he has successfully
defended while the vanquished suffers
more than just the agony of
defeat his back is carved
open and by Sunset the crocodiles are
watching
closely
they'd be unlikely to take on a bull in
rude
Health but now they Circle an
expectation the hippo breathes his
last the price of
insurrection is
[Music]
life his Hulk will not go to
waste
[Music]
the crocodiles move in swiftly to Feast
on the
corpse for these voracious Predators
it's a considerable
meal but one dead hippo is a mere snack
compared with the annual Feast provided
by a particular African
river
[Music]
each year the serengetti vast grass
Plains filled to the Horizon with
grazing animals taking part in one of
Nature's greatest
spectacles around 1 and2 million wilder
beast join 700,000 other herbivores on
the Great
Migration around 1 in six of these
migrants will die before completing the
500 M
circuit many are
outrun and taken down
down by Africa's formidable array of
Savannah
[Music]
carnivores their Journey coming to a
Grizzly
[Applause]
end but one of the deadliest single
obstacles the vast herds must
Traverse is the mara River
[Music]
after 3 months on the move the
wilderbeast are exhausted and
[Music]
emaciated all that separates them from
the Fresh pastures of the msai mara is
the width of the
[Music]
river and a whole bunch of huge ravit
Nile
crocodiles despite the chilling threat
posed by these powerful
Predators some of the herd are either
oblivious to the
danger or so thirsty they dare to take a
drink
anyway
for an unlucky few it will be their
[Applause]
last and these witless victims merely
wet the Croc's
appetite
the true Feast begins when the first of
the herd Braves the
[Music]
river in the crush and Chaos of the
crossing the 16t Crocs grabs scores of
victims
when 1,600 lb of muscle teeth and
ancient Killer Instinct latches
on resistance is
[Applause]
futile
the marus Crocs survive on meager
rations for most of the
year so take full advantage of the great
migrations time of
Plenty they Gorge
themselves eating up to half their body
weight in one
sitting and with so many different
species crossing the river
the banquet is as varied as it is
[Music]
Bountiful but not all Africa's Crocs
have such an easy meal
[Applause]
ticket on the banks of this Kenyon River
a Croc has got too close to a pack of
feeding
Lions a move it's about to
[Applause]
regret it's a fierce
attack but the Crocs skin is covered in
bony armor
plating eventually the Lion's Uninvited
Guest
Retreats having taught the Crocs and
dinner manners the big cats return to
the
carcass the Amazon is a giant of a river
and and conceal some monstrous
Predators which kill with a
crush and in a bloody
frenzy draining a lowland Basin of close
to 3 million square miles around 1/5 of
the water that runs off the earth's
surface is carried by the Amazon
this giant of a river is renowned for
its oversized
residence both
prey and
[Music]
Predator around 4 ft long and and
weighing as much as an adult human
capibara are the world's largest
rodent they're highly social animals and
extended families can be found living
along the banks of much of the
Amazon semi aquatic capibara never stray
too far from the
water grazing on flooded grasslands or
vegetation at the river's
fringes and this group has been joined
among the Water hent by another giant
Amazonian with carnivorous
intentions the green anaconda is the
world's largest snake growing up to 40
ft long and weighing as much as 500
lb
despite the copy Bar's size they're on
the menu of this enormous
reptile the family frics heedless of the
stocking
Predator it sents the air with its
forked tongue to locate its
prey
[Music]
[Applause]
the strike is
Swift once the capibara is entrapped in
the leviathan's thick
coils the more it struggles the tighter
the snake
grips it crushes its victim preventing
it from breathing and its blood from
circulating
in a fatal
Embrace finally the Anaconda stretches
its elastic jaw to swallow the capibara
hole but it's paid a price the copy
Bar's sharp teeth have left their
mark
this kill will feed the Anaconda for
weeks and it will remain dormant for
several days while digesting the
meal so the remaining capy baras are SA
safe at least from this river
monster with the world's most aggressive
Crocs concealed in the
water Rivers down under can be a deadly
place to hang
[Music]
[Applause]
out great
whites venomous
snakes
spiders and even deadly
jellyfish Australia is notorious for
lethal
Wildlife its rivers are infested by the
largest Crocs on the
planet so taking a dip here can be
[Applause]
life-threatening
during the monsoon in Australia's
tropical Northeast when it rains it
pours Rivers burst their Banks swamping
the surrounding
Plains and after the storms pass and the
flood water subsides the pools left over
are known as
bongs these isolated ponds support a
multitude of Life both above
and below the
[Music]
surface they are a place of
congregation a drinking hall for many
locals and many more just passing
[Music]
through little red flying foxes are a
nomadic species and now it's dusk tens
of thousands re-embark on the continual
search for flowering eucalyptus
[Music]
trees parched from a day roosting in the
Sun the bats swoop down for a drink and
it's an aerobatic feat they must get
just
right Predators
[Music]
await freshwater crocodiles are patient
Hunters
remaining concealed until a bat skims
the water within
range and every so often the bats make a
fatal
[Applause]
error it's not just on their nightly
excursions flying foxes must be wary
even while roosting they're in danger
from Australia's many killer
[Music]
Critters so flying fox colonies take
security
seriously roosting in numbers reduces
the risk from predators and the camp
also posts
centuries old males guard the
boundaries
a carpet python will swallow a bat
hole but flying foxes have great
[Music]
eyesight he escapes to a safer
Branch or at least safer from the
[Music]
python
a saltwater croc slips through the water
[Music]
below growing up to 23 ft long these
armor-plated predators are the largest
living reptile and the most aggressive
crocodilians on the
planet but while they may be more
fearsome than their freshwater
relatives it turns out they share a
taste for flying
[Music]
[Applause]
fox
salties as the AIS call them are the
stuff of
nightmares they can lunge
explosively launching their whole body
length out of the
water
and with the strongest bite force of any
known
Predator they kill most prey with a
single snap of their
jaws but for some females at least the
urge to kill gives way to a gentler
Instinct at a certain time of
year during the months they incubate
their eggs moms to be usually
fast her clutch is buried in a nest
which she will fiercely
defend just Downstream a lace monitor
enjoys
lunch a kangaroo
carcass its fly bitten meal is scavenged
Carion but these huge lizards also hunt
down small mammals reptiles and
[Music]
birds
and it's one of very few animals that
will dare to raid a crocodile
[Music]
Nest the brooding mother abandons her
watch to cool
off allowing the monitor lizard its
chance to Stage an audacious
[Music]
raid
driven by hunger the 6ot long lizard is
merciless but its appetite may prove to
be
[Music]
deadly this time the plunder escapes
with its life
and a full
belly while the Croc returns to brood
what's left of her
eggs rivers are highways of
life but they can also be a death
trap sometimes Staying Alive means
running through the
traffic
for some species of migratory fish
rivers of the route back to their place
of birth to spawn the Next
Generation while Riverbanks provide a
nursery where young mammals graze
idly and both the influx of greeters and
heedless Offspring lay on an easy Feast
for
predators to survive
they must
run most species of salmon undertake a
mighty migratory
run and in Alaska salmon have more than
just waterfalls to contend
with grizzly bears are expert
[Music]
fishermen
having made it up the waterfalls these
weary scky salmon rest in the
shallows they are close to Journey's End
and have turned Scarlet ahead of
spawning but first they must summon the
energy to beat yet another
obstacle driven by the need to breathe
the salmon power their way through the
shallows
the commotion attracts the attention of
another notorious Alaskan
killer wolves hunt deer for most of the
year but actually prefer salmon when
they're in plentiful
Supply although that doesn't mean
they're easy to
catch
[Music]
during the summer months the wolf will
plunder the salmon run time and
again but this one's going to need to
find a new fishing
spot standing on his hind legs the
grizzli is a full 8T of scary the Lone
Wolf has little choice but to
run with the river to itself the bear
can focus on
fishing it's a more skillful Dash and
grab Hunter than its K9
competitor the bear uses its huge claws
to skewer the fish against the
bottom before clamping it with massive
[Music]
teeth Grizzlies pursue salmon so
relentlessly that they can eat up to 100
lbs of this flapping delicacy in one
day and these intimidating Bears prowess
in the water equips them to take out
larger prey Than Just
Fish
around 1500 Mi South the Yellowstone
River cuts through the national park
which took its
name its spring in meltwater has swollen
the flow over lower Falls to impressive
[Music]
proportions a little way Downstream a
group of elk grazes at the water's edge
and a Grizzly mom spies an opportunity
to feed her hungry
Cubs there are calves among the elk and
with the river running high they are all
but
trapped the youngster's mother spots the
Bears and abandons her
offspring
[Music]
the grizzly can outcharge a galloping
horse and unfortunately for the
Cales it can also outswim an
[Music]
Olympian
incredibly Both calves make it to the
far bank but not out of
danger as mother elk watches
on the grizzly drags its victim from the
river but just as she's about to make
the kill she's
distracted
her Cubs are following her tracks a move
that may prove deadly for these young
swimmers she must decide between a meal
and her
Offspring The reprieve is
brief
injured and dazed the calf is easy to
haul
[Music]
down when the Congo River dries up the
truly evolved can still
survive but what proves a lifesaver in
the dry season May yet spell Doom in the
West
A Primitive killer is
lurking mankind has been fishing rivers
for at least 4,000
[Music]
years but there's an African freshwater
Predator which has been honing its
angling skills since prehistoric
times the Congo has been flowing since a
time when Africa and South America still
formed a single super continent over 140
million years
ago and it is a battlefield for ancient
adversaries
in the vast bangu ULU Wetlands at the
head of the River
Basin a lofty bird stalks the
undergrowth standing 4T tall the shoe
Bill stor is an imposing
Predator its beak is 9 in Long four wide
with a vicious hook at the tip to grip
and Pierce its
prey but perhaps its greatest
weapon is
[Music]
stealth
the shoe Bill dispatches the Weaver
chick with a snap of its
beak before swallowing it
hole and there's one last mouth for Mom
to
feed for some survival in the bangu ULU
involves evading the same foe every year
when the wet season shifts to dry the
giant swamp's waterways shrink and turn
to
mud a fatal seasonal transformation for
fish or so you
think there is a prehistoric creature
that has performed the same death
defying trick for nearly 400 million
years thanks to primitive lungs the West
African lungfish can breathe
air and survive outside of
water once buried in a chamber beneath
the mud it spews out a mucus cocoon
which seals moisture around its
body the Hardy fish then Waits out the
dry season
[Music]
underground at last
rain and the bangu ULU is once again
submersed now now the ground is soft the
swamp
erupts the lungfish rise like the dead
from shallow
Graves they've been buried for only
months but could have survived out of
water for
years it's an incredible Escape
tactic but once back in the water the
adaptation which helped them survive the
dry season is exploited by an old
[Music]
enemy every 30 minutes the lungfish must
breathe and the shoe Bill
[Music]
Waits
its strike is Swift and
uniring it's hooked beak
tenacious sharp enough to decapitate its
victim the lungfish loses this round of
an ageold
battle the am Amazon has its
stranglers the Nile heavyweight
Killers but Us Rivers also have their
share American
assassins America's waterways land of
the Frog home of the
bass which is of course bad news for the
Frog
and there are a whole lot more hidden
killers and explosive
attackers which means taking a drink
from these Us
Rivers could prove
fatal some 2,300 Mi after flowing out of
Lake
itasa the Mississippi reaches the Gulf
of
Mexico here's sediment carried by this
most soulful of rivers has over the
course of thousands of years created the
Mississippi
Delta and a wetland Paradise for
hundreds of animal
species white tailed deer have
flourished in the
Delta and wherever this gentle species
thrives so do the hardened Hunters which
prey on
[Music]
them fully grown American alligators are
the Undisputed apex predator of the
Mississippi
River with 150 million years to perfect
its hunting technique the alligator has
a brutally efficient method for killing
land-based
prey
[Music]
it will wait for its victim to take a
drink and
then this time the deer is
lucky
and the hungry Gator melts back into the
river's
depths it can remain submerged for up to
hours plenty of time to let an
unsuspecting meal stroll within striking
range
[Music]
[Applause]
the gator dispatches the pig
swiftly crushing its victim to death
with a bite force of over 2,000
lb but to tear off a mouthful of Flesh
the gator must death
roll it's a maneuver which can be
performed
solo but a second gator has got in on
the pig ripping
action and the ravenous pair dismembers
the carcass with
[Applause]
ease now the kill is in bites sized
pieces bite-sized that is for a 14t
reptile the gator can swallow down its
meal meanwhile the Killer's spinning
assistant makes off with a share of the
meat Fair reward for giving a neighbor a
leg
up while Gators top the Mississippi's
Predator pile these gut-wrenching
Killers aren't old Muddy's only
explosive Ambush
Hunter common snapping turtles are
highly aggressive and will eat almost
anything they can get their trap jawed
mouths
around they will stock prey slowly
before unleashing a lightning
attack or lie in wait for an
unsuspecting victim to swim within range
then snatch it with a bite capable of
tearing
flesh but when it comes to snap happy
Predators the Mississippi has just one
true
king and even heavily armored snapping
turtles must fear its
[Applause]
wrath trapped in the vice likee grip of
the Gator's Jaws the turtle's tough
shell is all that's keeping it
alive though not for
[Music]
long it's a crunchy
mouthful with a soft
Center like a hard candy for
[Music]
Gators but it's a Bitter End for the
turtle on this River of
[Music]
death